- that was a changeover Ferg identified
some community that have been really
wonderful
alii Genesis to assemble them and we're
gonna have a little conversation about
some of the questions that came up in
the performance as an artist you often
don't get an opportunity to open up your
work to people who are doing the work
you want to talk about in your work
right so then we working in silos often
would just like the community that we're
working with so the great thing about
being here at MIT and be in this cast
residency is that we've had an
opportunity to meet some really great
people so if we could get some chairs
out here at sundown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everyone set Abigail down in a
second for the first thing I would like
to do is ask the panelists to introduce
themselves
we had an opportunities of us have met
in October some of us who just met just
about an hour ago and so this is a
really an amazing group of people that
are doing some really important work
this community Boston Cambridge area so
so everyone's changed Dallas Texas
graduated now at a Harvard Divinity
School I also work as a chaplain my
particular interests are the
intersections of music and art theology
and activism I'm a musician
I've also don't work black lives matter
came here so interested in the ways that
our discourse about God and humanity can
be enriched my name is Ashley roads I'm
an educator I work at the community
Academy science and health and I also
teach art there I'm so I'm really
excited to see them bridge the gap
between stem and steam where's the main
calm and I'm really excited to be here
because I was buying
but they're the kids where art and
science cooks that so to see am I to do
that to be polite smile inside fact they
are some solutions good evening my name
is Nia Evans with the boss media project
in Boston in Boston we are bringing
together community members especially
for small businesses funders to pull
their resources and create a community
controlled capital investment fund and
local community also do my creative
partners in the audience too much to
Jackson or shatter out we also do work
where we combine art policy and what's
what's interesting about tonight and
when war intersects with b-boy I would
say is with when it comes to an
invention and experimentation and child
and allowing us to consider
possibilities imagine Selena disaster
social intervention awesome
I company called the ADA barber LLC and
one of our first initiatives is peace
but originally from Billings Montana
came out there exploiting cameras and
then went back to Montana to do my
Master's an interval I know cultural
Youth and Family Development so out here
this is our community for a little bit
of working on social justice and
activism has always kind of been in my
mainstream so I'm very thankful to be
there good evening my name is cathlin
Juarez native of Austin founder and
executive director of dams fest Boston
our music soul clefts the reason why
I've started organizations because
because I saw a 30 year deficit in the
city when it came around entertainment
particularly for African Americans
we have many underutilized green spaces
that are not used and what that does
that impacts health I'm a perception of
where people live and the distances and
how many perceive our neighborhoods the
reason why I'm here is because of the
fact of I believe in the power of Arts
and has an impact on young people but
also its power of connecting generations
and considering the city that we live in
right now where were number one and
everything else we also have deficits in
other areas and
in arts and culture some very my name is
Marsha and Anita I am there to
cigarettes organic hands which is a
dance theater social justice oriented
dance theater company I am also the
founder of the panel festival we create
celebrating women in the arts the work
that I'm focused on right now is
important we talk and the Diaspora in
the United States
for those of you don't know mostly not a
social media and in general here there's
a lot going on infertility codes a big
big big crisis and the work that I'm
doing right now focuses on that and as
it pertains also to blackness and
colonialism good evening my name is
Brandon G green local boston-based
actors creative playwright educators
recently from Selma Alabama um so this
isn't my blood uh-huh so justice and I'm
working on one-man show entitled um
it stands for identity of the martyrs
and talks about the war on black and
brown bodies and it's a cyclical nature
of our Martin women town soon in what's
up y'all
my name is cliff notes Boston born
raised artists I run a company called
hipstery and that focuses on the
redefining of the future history of hip
hop and what that means is we're a film
and music company just has it now hoping
to expand but that focuses on creating
artwork that always has a connection to
hip hop in some way and also realizing
that hip hop started with marginalized
voices and marginalised stories in those
of the stories that we look to tell so
for example our recent films that we've
been doing around colleges around New
England is - psychological thrillers
about mental health of black Americans
and we're also working on several albums
that have similar subject matter and
also looking at intersectionality and
art in general just like people is doing
good to see y'all my name is Debbie T
Brown I'm originally from the planet of
Brooklyn always reside here in Cambridge
but worked in conference where at a
school called cognitive Kadim each other
public school we are a k-12 experience
of learning social justice oriented arts
and wellness initiative housed
outward-facing
like a school but not quite and I'm
excited to be part of a conversation
that is trying to draw connections and
intersections between all the different
elements that are named here today
because our students are always in
between the never in one spot and it's
always beautiful to try to find those
those entry points so that they can also
walk away some strong skills sparked
forth
hi Abigail de ville costumes and I'm
site specific installation artist from
the Bronx but mostly my work focuses on
purposely erased histories in the United
States and abroad and I use black holes
as a metaphor for historical erasure
so the structures that I create loosely
talk to cosmology and the fact that
black holes are invisible so it's a
container of whatever great so I'm gonna
what we're gonna do is I'm going to pose
a question and then I'm gonna let
whoever wants to respond to the question
just reach for a mic and and respond
okay
so thinking about the fact that bodies
are speaking realities that aren't
actually being talked about right at
this point in time we're thinking about
bead colony collapse syndrome thinking
about the silencing of black and brown
people through police brutality poor
education mass incarceration
gentrification the list goes on and on
and on so my question is ten making art
actually help to rebuild communities how
and why is that important
I'm absolutely sure czar and once I
actually think it can help to rebuild
communities especially if you start
thinking about in regards to colonies we
can learn a lot from animals I think
from whether it's you think about
bridges or cranes but even bees not only
from their collapse but also think about
how resilient they are in regards to the
swarm fairy if you think about art and
cartoons like back in the day first
thing the bees would do is kind of like
take a shape of a fish start back like
chase you you're gonna need your kind of
like slamming into a wall I think if we
kind of think about being resilient like
that black lives matter which is not
what a real leader you could kill rugby
but everyone has their on stinger their
own boy is a little bit of honey to give
so on I think about if you start think
about we are the kind of related arts
and bees and humanity before but it's
harder for there are reason which
they've actually given and lived in
persevere definitely so I teach with all
the I dream program here in Boston
through Emerson College it is Daniel
babies program pulling like amazing does
everything basic but what we do is going
to schools I think we're a common last
year but I'm currently at a snow
now and what we do is we get the kids in
the community to one tell their story
and then to write it and create it so
it's about transforming your pain into
power it's this whole thing and how do
you write the past write your past down
in the crazy future so they are telling
their stories and then imagining and
working towards a brighter future for
themselves and think about where the the
change is going to come from it's from
them as they come up as they become
leaders and yeah definitely bringing it
back to Puerto Rican what amazed moved
to New York and Boston and I it's really
heartbreaking what's happening in Puerto
Rico right now
and it's even more heartbreaking than
the United States it's not taking
ownership through the media you don't
see it if you open the time to just
won't see it and so I think the arts is
a great way to like first of all create
awareness so with this new piece
separately in Milazzo
we're telling some of those stories and
what I'm doing is I'm collaborating with
people from the community of Puerto Rico
so interviews through Helio we're gonna
do exchange and in conversations with
them like that because the history is
trying to get erased we don't want to
talk about it we're like in that hole
like what's gonna go I don't know if
anybody here knows but inside it's
something that they'd rather not talk
about
and so the arts I think it's just like
pivotal in telling the story for
audiences that might not hear about it
otherwise and then powering the country
that is really they're working really
hard and is empowering the country
they're cutting 512 million dollars for
University importantly which is my alma
mater which will quickly the stabilize
the education system I can go on and on
but I realize in the arts and that's
theater to build immunity strengthen the
Puerto Rican community here at Boston
New York and then create a bridge
a group called epic Cobra and I think my
work with that my services assistant for
four years and him and I are still good
friends and in touch differently but the
car changed my life I covered that dirt
road in Montana until I was you know
like ten years old and then moved into
the city space and I think that my
interaction like learning about the
blackout's movement was something that
completely reformed me like an
individual and 2010 and I attended like
a conference pad UMass called our car
movement and amiri baraka spoke it
Sanchez spoke and at the end of Sonia
Sanchez speaking and I was just all
about like her poetry from the beginning
and I was like you know what we do to
like eliminate you know this fear is
such a good lady
he breaks us all apart that we as human
beings have created and she was like
sister and my sister what we just need
to build a united front and I was like
yeah but it was really it was through
art because I think it's a player like
expression that allows people to and I
think when you talk about bodies and you
talk about violence against life
in the United States I study yoga and
I'm like and I've been kind of like
within this space and there's something
to say about like the souls that live in
these bodies but there's something to
respect about the box that were in and
an art is a way of being able to kind of
like see and express that I think I'm
really feel that from an emotional like
level of space so yeah I do think that
like art is the main like I think it is
the mechanism into one in one or two
bring people together into do these
things
thank you you know I think a lot about
art being a way that you can transcend
what the dominant culture says about you
you can redefine yourself and I think
that is something that really stands for
me I think about a lot I have a question
so are we getting too comfortable with
these epic scale dentists that are
happening right now I think absolutely
and almost unintentionally which is the
scary part I recently made a film
thinking about dating back to Tamir rice
and I was really just reflecting on last
summer
every summer really but just the amount
of people that were dying and how often
it was just everywhere and I was like
trying to finish up grad school and
trying to work full-time is trying to
psych this company and at the same time
I'm waking up every morning and seeing
somebody die after I went after somebody
else what somebody else had to birthday
on Facebook and that's it's literally
the way media is and how it's literally
being force-fed to us and it's hard not
to realize that's half
I mean I mean I remember when I was
young there this isn't a long time for
though this is like seven years ago but
I just remember just like any like overt
amount of violence that you were seeing
on television or anything like snuff
films were such like a rarity and now
it's literally everyday thing and you
can see from Leno Castille diet right
now that can pull your phone out and see
somebody die and it's it's painful and I
think one of the main things we need to
take note of is that yes we need to
protest and yes we need to go out and do
something but I think the number one win
over everything is figuring out how we
can take care of ourselves so amongst us
and self-care is like this new
revolutionary thing to me and and
because I'm a black man and it's just
never been something that was
highlighted it's always been taking care
of everybody else and I think that is
probably the most important bringing
forward
yeah I think I think there's something
really maybe it's just a human thing but
I think it's especially our American
that we can so easily digest human death
like that's not normal like that's not
natural like I think a lot of times we
are desensitized maybe by necessity to
the atrocity of the human life taking
but that is I think that's you know that
is the tragedy every time it happens and
I mean I love action like I'm a huge
football fan and I can just digest this
stuff all day long but I think it has to
come a moment and this isn't even new
like you know lynchings used to be a
public spectacle people sleeping their
kids to mention it's a family affair
only way you can get passed on but like
chata slate is if you know kill though
very few the part of yourself to digest
human death in that way I think we're in
a moment now what we really need to take
a step back in the sit-in the horror of
darker bodies millions and billions of
guide images being snuffed out like that
is that is a tragedy worth reflecting in
city in order to even begin to address
liberation work is to recognize what is
being lost and even when people aren't
actually dying what kinds of lives are
they living you know solid into housing
segregation sex labor is still a big
poverty
I think an XOS fire so much of this
justice work has to begin with
understanding the value of a human life
so I absolutely think we're a crisis
moment in tells us how we dull and how
we can place the land of testing on
repeat after weekend after weekend so I
was just gonna say I think based on what
you would you say in terms of
recognizing the horror like there's a
piece where we don't recognize the way
in which black life which is a different
thing than black lives I mean all of us
like there's a way in which the way that
the stories get punctuated in terms of
this black like this black like this
black life but this is a part of the
larger social history that's about a
devaluing of black life and it's about
us it's about me it's not about these
punctuation and individuals and we don't
necessarily right now have a way to make
sense of how but at this particular
epoch what's what's at stake with the
presenting black life and outside of
subjectivity presenting my life as if
black life is still child I think that
ways in which but this warming I'm
Krystina shoppers with this book lock in
the wake and one of the things she poses
is is this moment in afterlife slavery
and in it she also poses like all the
subjects does the United States see
as a subject or we some outside like
senator Mills place where we don't as
our does my existence back and I think
those are the kinds of questions that we
can actually trouble disembark and
ritual and spirit and design and I think
that until we want start to see us as I
don't think we see ourselves as we if we
we have to learn how to CSS as we again
somehow and it's the only which teaches
us to be eyes not knees and then from
there try to proceed in a context that
doesn't recognize our subjectivity
that's part subjects in the United
States we're floating objects as sort of
the detritus of child labor
well once we sort of wrap our minds and
our spirits about that how to proceed in
a context which tells us that over and
over again I think those other kinds of
questions we need to grapple with and I
think we can and in order to deal with
that we have to we have to pull on us
about and I think that that's what
really gives us an opportunity to do it
it's time and the thing that's really
interesting about this moment is the
intensity and the speed of the episodes
in the episodic and it creates its own
set of punctuation and then I find
myself and I find all of them we get
triggered by the punctuation which makes
it in passive
to actually conceive of how to deal with
this borrower in something lots of
different tricks that make it really
really complicated in each pilot to
orientate ourselves to this particular
moment in time and I think one of some
of the things we have to do we wire
spirit crime a bunch of together about
what we're actually up to the audience
so Guillermo mentioned in the
performance that you know bees are
hooked on antibiotics right so all the
bees that are caught up pollinating all
of our food yeah they're they're
drinking this mixture of sugar water and
antibiotics in order to do that right so
humans are also hooked on drugs right
whether they may be prescription whether
it be sugar whether it be bad food
whatever it is I'm wondering can we
survive without drugs or other legalized
killers of the body and spirit how can
we rebuild and prepare and how to
nourish ourselves with liberating food
education and culture I want to connect
this begs a question I went to high
school I would avoid he was killed by
organ and s so when I think about the
addictions are now at the media and
people like rehashed having murder as we
start on a hashtag which was stop
normalizing the murder
[Music]
which should start serving playing these
which they start highlighting you know
therefore families whether it's Aaron's
family
oh that's family are the two Cape
Verdean in general these mothers are
crying these are families that are
really still hurt so we have to stop
this addiction to social media in
feeding that feed in itself I feel like
that's one of things we're talking about
a diet feeding sugar etc but what you're
feeding is so low that regards to what
you're ingesting on your news feeds when
you turn on that TV and what you're
putting back in those news feeds I think
are a lot more even more important than
what we're actually just in regards to
food we got to be the more organic
without thought so that'd be something
[Applause]
woody going to sacrifice to start over
we're in a country and to bring it down
to down to box but we're in a place of
convenience your car can park for you
either stop the shot to deliver
groceries like be the magnitude of
socialization is so limited by
convenience and it's such a struggle and
we're talking about black and brown
bodies when it comes of things just like
food and I know there's these
interesting movements around organic and
eating holes and all these other things
but if you came out the womb
what's a lollipop you're going to grow
that love versus someone who came out of
wound with some orange and between our
school systems our Parenthood of just
environment you have these flashing
images in this kind of genetic
information passed down above what's
good for you was not good for you so by
the time that child grows up the
decisions are already made and they
stick with that foundation so my
question has always been are we willing
as individuals with us as a collective
of people willing to flesh out our
system to start over again and a lot of
us don't want to do that because it
tastes too good it's just too damn good
to let go and if I do who's going to
hold my hand through this process and
there's go to sacrifice as as the world
is never straight and narrow it's always
going to be bumpy I don't know if a lot
of us are ready to do that we can't
return on cable or see you know Real
Housewives of Atlanta it's just too good
but imagine if as the novel's talk to my
mother about this is she always gets on
younger generations about the simple
tool of writing a letter no one knows
how to write letters or checks or how to
how to sign it and everything is by
thumb now and kids are at an alarming
rate of getting arthritis in their
phones by the time you're 21 it's crazy
but if you take that away from them it's
like they're dying but are they really
know that all they know that came out
the wall boom so she was right there the
the the development of books and being
outdoors for more than seven minutes
which is a statistic right now is that
young people between the ages of 14 and
21 sweats spend less than seven minutes
outdoors I'm sure there's some people in
this - would have spent my whole damn
day and waited for their mom or their
father to call them back in the house
that doesn't happen anymore so now you
have this isolation in which then this
is not going to come at it I just hope
that at some point we recognize that we
are sitting in a pool of convenience and
until we're ready to drain it and our
skeletons will be unveiled balance of
what we did that please friends and
acquaintances who are in recovery from
addiction because at containment
survivors in
like I don't know - and when I think
about a ditch so for me this question is
actually committed a couple of the
couple of the other questions as well
and when I think about addiction and I
think about from what I understand from
my peers with some roots of addiction
are and and they're usually less about
the particular drug particular material
I'm also thinking about Gemma Brittany
that used to Professor Tony a car
something and he talks about the
difference between certain types of
duties and actual addiction so I also
think about how we have tools in our
society there are points our tools are
useful up to a certain point and then
beyond a certain point they become
dangerous and I think you just spoke
about that a little bit so when I think
about the root of the struggles that
people have a lot of it in my
understanding is the lack of hope a lot
of new well-being a lack of a certain
type of health you know definitely
whatever the person's personal struggles
are search for a type of love and the
way it connects attendant the first two
questions for me is you know we've we've
just talked about pretty missus how hard
life is life is hard and you know
they're probably people amongst us who
could probably remember when a wife was
easier I think most of us community
today it's hard for a lot of us whatever
our background is and so the note that
makes me think about what it whatever
what does it redeeming value what is
value in society and considering each
other's
mental health thinking about support
systems that we can create so when I
think about the redeeming value I think
about what it is that we can create to
lessen the boils of follow than that for
things that are comin at us and so then
when we think about four different tools
at our disposal and when we think about
what maybe reach out to what we're
struggling we have some boxes so that we
can reach out the social media or
synthetic drugs or a friend or a
conversation or a diary we recognize
that we can maybe recognize that that we
have a few different options and also
just really think about how we can
create a society where people can just
be which is absolutely we can't just be
right so I think that that is a resource
I'll show you I was thinking a lot about
about what it means to be young in this
society and how spawn effects today and
think a lot about some of our ninety
students are 14 15 year-olds and I
supposed to mention they just they don't
walk without this in their hands like
this and then are very very interested
in that sort of beef patty right before
coming into school and right to the sort
of Skittles right after school was over
and that and I talked on a lot about
what is what does wellness mean to you
and how can you eat healthy so it's your
body's in better shape what does that
look like you feel like and I but I know
I feel like a lot of it is about Nesta
size it a lot of it it's about just
taken away the pain and when I ask
questions they lash out often so one of
the things I think about this I the I
culture that is missing from our
culture's is the self care piece of it
and what can we do and I one of the
things I try to do as an educator is to
model that and say I am also addicted to
my phone I want to check the news I want
to look at my fantasy baseball team I
need to figure out if the Knicks laws
they always do so I'm also addicted to
my phone but I'm also working very hard
to fight that addiction and here the
ways that I do that I love McDonald's
french fries I love them I haven't had a
dunk french fries in seven years I mean
clean
[Applause]
and I know I'm gonna be a better
my body's better my life's gonna be
better it's am NOT on that McDonald's
franchise and it's right across the
street from the school so it's our so
but how did that come sis also think
being honest about our own [ __ ] right
not not lying to our children like we
are holier than thou we are all
struggling and that's a [ __ ] and so that
I think is an important piece about
about these addictions we got a
vulnerable and we got to talk about them
you gotta help people to break through
so I'm just playing the back foot
catalyst and you literally took the
words out of my mouth thinking about how
we're living in an instantaneous society
and you need everything now we get up
now and you can get anything you want in
seconds and I think that very much ties
into all of this because yes we need to
take care of ourselves and yes we need
to do all these things and eat bread and
it's not that I don't know these things
it's just that it's going to take way
longer than what we expected it won't
we're conditioned to having and I think
that is one of the hardest things to
realize in all of us I could become a
vegan but it's gonna take a while for my
body to adjust to that and we we know
what we can do to try and make change
but we have to realize that the major
change is probably not going to happen
in any of our lifetimes but if you stop
now that nothing is going to change just
like we need to continue to make those
steps every day and make some type of
change in our lives and some type of
changing other people's lives in their
lives and I thought in the sea
that you're gonna plant to have that
tree grow at the time um so I have a
couple more questions but I think what
I'm gonna do is open these questions up
to the panelists but also to the
audience we have a couple of microphones
dance and if you don't we're trying to
record this it would be great if you
wouldn't mind speaking and we can turn
up the lights please Susan thank you if
you have a response you want to just
walk up to one of the microphones and if
you wouldn't mind stating your name and
then like if you have an affiliation
with MIT or like what your connection is
so I'm just gonna pose these two
questions and then it's like kind of
free food whoever would like to answer
so we were talking about the second
place in the performance right and my
question is at what point did we pull
ourselves out how do we awaken ourselves
save ourselves each other in the planet
how do we choose a better way to live
and what kind of transformation is
necessary and essential for that and
then I mean there's more than one
question but you gotta say and then on
another side the other question is so
we've been talking a lot about a lot of
social justice issues and aren't issues
and I'm wondering you know we're also
interested in collecting data and
there's a lot of data that's not being
collected we're in a research
institution here and so people are
collecting data all the time
and in the case of issues that deal with
a lot of black of brown people data is
being ignored so I'm interested to know
what data do you think we need to be
focused on collecting in the future
so yeah just connectedness to the to the
last questions fascinated for me to
think about how what what bees are made
to consume being the antibiotics in the
sugar water it doesn't kind of work on
their bodies for particular purpose
which I don't know to me feels very
sexual like a pollinating project of
reproduction so you know there's there's
a there's an ingestion of the thing for
particular purpose so how that ties into
the you know black and brown dark body
to general life of me is thinking about
what is it that we are actually made to
consume it happens that in body itself
in different kinds of ways of being in
actions quick example Flint Michigan
still doesn't have clean water kids are
still drinking LED and then needs to
verify children's
so I guess in this is that it's not the
father to people it's like why are not
we can do right places what's wrong with
us but these dis is systemic like he
said it across to school is a methanol
it's like wide so speaking of danger
like why are wising that if you know
most of poor communities but you see
around us like the little boy there guys
that's how you like the pink Drew's and
then
you know sneakers bars you know all of
that so that lets me like the choices
are pretty good in them if you go to
Whole Foods you know oh great you know
but you can afford it you know so you
know what what are you feeding people of
color in you know in especially you know
in the communities that that are in need
those aren't does the information that
we need to find out like what if we know
that its strategic I you know I hate to
be like the conspiracy theory or
whatever but there is a reason reason
why you know you go to two Egleston
square you see I am gonna go subscribe
and you know everything when I we have
to get out of my neighborhood to get you
know the food that my body will be
comfortable with and it could have a
tough life
so I just think it's important to
consider that they think that everything
I just said also like thank producer
from a church that schools that can say
to the children listen I know that these
are the choices around here but here are
other choices that you can affordably
consider things that are healthy for
your body and I'm just going to say the
suck in case is a an individual it's not
like I'm in a sucking place it's it's
it's a metaphor for condition that we
share and the other thing I was gonna
say it's back to what you guys are
saying like then if we are in the second
place I can't then deal with my personal
getting out of it if we have a second
place that we have to get out of it
that requires us to think where are we
and whither in space and where is that
space and then how to be reconfigured
the space if we don't think spatially if
we don't actually get to the spaces
where we all have to reconfigure how we
are together with ourselves
there will be no getting out of the
sunken space so I just want to like say
those we're bodies and there are things
happening to us but there's more to our
subjectivity than just our bodies
there's a spaces where we inhabit the
objects that are implicit in how we are
together those things get designed this
doesn't there's a lot more to what it
means to be together right so in order
to really figure out this this metaphor
the second space we've got to look at
the context that were sunken and rethink
it all like it's a it's a fascinating
time in terms of sort of reimagining
what does it mean to be human what does
it mean to be a lot but a lot for us to
do that it requires looking at
everything I think I spend a lot of time
thinking about like the imagery and
thinking
about water and I always think about
like reflections right so whenever I see
me I see the reflection of week like
consistently and I think that a lot of
folks get into when we talk about a lot
of this is about violence right and like
about and it's about cycles of violence
look kind of consistent like throughout
history and it's about that's like
Workington about those cycles and what
that looks like and I think like in
reference like getting out of the second
space one I think that we have to stop
being something so bad against ourselves
myself like why would you do that myself
about like sir like what do you that
extra don't little things like that but
then I think then you can start to if
you can be more compassionate with
yourself you can start to be more
compassionate with everybody else around
you and I think that that is like one of
the spaces that we need to start to like
work from in order to be able to see
people in different spaces and places
and then are able to develop more
authentic space based on people coming
together and recognizing the real life
situations that everybody has been in in
the historical of questions in the
historical trauma and everything
that is tied to bonds and biology you
know and and I think and that's like I'm
not a scientist that's a huge
complicated like mess like when I start
to think about it I thought I definitely
spent time I'd like concentrate on you
know I think the place that we need to
focus on in terms of where we go to is
like it's and I think like kind of
answering the question about like
research and how do we look at you know
data I always had like an issue or like
within statistics because we're always
talking about numbers and I could never
get it like I took statistics twice in
college accidentally I really don't and
at the end of both terms that's like so
you're telling me that like just plus or
minus is essentially that me being able
to sway a number to the right or to the
left
in whatever way I want to see thick I
was like well that doesn't like resonate
with me like and I was like but where's
the qualitative in that like how do you
document quality different like how does
I know what I really feel like
especially when you think about bodies
because there's cycle resonance in
bodies right and I think that there's
and it's a vibration like I mean we talk
about art when we talk about drums and
we talk about all these things like it's
a vibration all of us and a lot of that
comes from energy and a lot of that
comes from water and you know 90% of the
earth is water seven percent of our
body's water you know and talk about
Flint when you talk about California and
they talk about these places right and
so I think that there's something to
investigate like with
I don't really exactly know like what
that is in terms of data but like I say
they're like the researchers to the
scientists in the room like I think that
there's some play thank you yeah the
wrong hello everybody my name is James
Magnum on community water diver the
national activist and I lead a movement
called step on replay and think of the
thinking about how we are in this
society that we live in there are a lot
of black and brown bodies who are
incarcerated who are enter entering the
in justice system and they're not a lot
of people out here really fighting for
them and so once you enter that system
it's like you're stuck and it's a cycle
that continues so if you think about it
people entering the criminal justice
system black and brown bodies you don't
know anything about it what we stuck on
Rico just want to say that real quick
what was your question your first
question was like extra long
[Music]
so I think the issue that is happening
around us and for our Depot and for us
the general right we don't question that
much anymore so when you were younger
you still question thing because I
remember when you know I grew up as a
Jehovah's Witness
and you know my grandmother wasn't that
way but then one day my mom decided to
go to church and I hear battles between
how my crown and I like you know grandma
as it is a wonderful person I looked at
the Christians as good people it's not
like why are two great people talking
about each other and they should be
great right they're great people and I
thought that at a young age and that's
what I really realized that you know I
have to start questioning issues between
and that's what I'm realizing like y'all
can't take people's you know words war
for what they said I have to question so
you don't think about the criminal
justice system how did so I do a lot
around
general I just want to you know talk
about how we don't question things so
people get locked up okay I'll get do we
have family that's willing to support
them they may pay for lawyer fees but
how far are you willing to go to fight
for your brothers or your sisters that's
locked up I remember when you know I'm
doing this work with stuff on replay and
my brother had got locked up and I was
like you know I've had a sit back shut
up and reflect on all this working
around coming just abuse war but I can't
do anything for my brother like that's
something something's not right about
this picture and then I had to start
making calls to those people who I felt
could make good support my brother and
I'm saying all that to say that we don't
question the problems anymore we just
you know you never we fitted so well we
know that we can get an opportunity we
get it out to get that opportunity and
we just shut up and keep it moving
because you know what we don't want to
mess it up for our family but also for
other people that come behind but that's
the issue what are we going to stand up
against and if we don't then we'll be
rights to my team in instance then I
mean electrical engineering computer
science and I guess my question is are
really good
they should after that discussion
because my question is about dreams and
sort of seeing all the role models in
front of me here today on the panel I
kind of think a lot about my own dreams
and sort of where I want to go in the
future and I want to be a professor when
I grow up I have this written down
because I tends a Hottentot upon
selected ones you know I'm so much
specific concern that the academic
career path is what Cornel West
describes the double bond but between
practitioners of color linking their
activities to the fundamental structural
overhaul of their sponsoring
institutions while needing to a main
financially dependent on them I wonder
what a career in academia looks like for
a person like myself knowing that
becoming a professor could provide a
powerful opportunity to serve as an
embodiment of intellectual Authority
challenging the devastating increase the
notion of black and black female
intellectual inferiority and so that's
what I want to be a professor but at the
same time access to my MIT I can
acknowledge that the food that I eat
comes from the same company eating
prison institutions and our first black
classroom I wanna make the 30th
anniversary photos of him were blocked
by the liquid-nitrogen teams I can't not
acknowledge those structural issues
within my own institution and so I
wonder how do you all
[Music]
Wow
you know if you like I'm on the spot
only because my relationship to to data
I think is a bit and live alone because
I also come from the background of black
marriage right the Haitian Revolution
and what that took was some secrecy
right no sharing of data so so it's it's
a difficult question to answer because I
think it would take more than a few
minutes and and I think it's a I really
do think you know the answer is one that
should be shared with a wider audience
but because I feel like it's also a
point of trauma for me thanks that it
would be it would be an answer that be
fleshed out much more deeply and
profoundly in a probably a personal
setting
I've had so many different moments in my
career as an artist
I wondered got a masters I got an a
buffet because I thought that would
allow me a little bit more access into
the Academy into institution which it
does but then I found out living in New
York City that you make more money as a
server and you talk don't you talk about
being a circle yeah you make more money
as a server or a bartender then being an
agile professor right so and then I did
I figured out that well by access is
limited because of this because the MFA
is only the the the highest degree in
art schools or an institutions that look
at the MFA as the the final the terminal
degree thank you very much so I'm like
oh I'm really gonna be competitive oh
hey I gotta get a PhD so then I found a
ph.d program
you know after 17 almost 20 years of
like being out in the world kind of
whatever faith and then I realized maybe
it's not that maybe that's about the
time maybe I should change my space
change my place to try to shake
something up so I left New York and that
changed you know I moved to Los Angeles
which was maybe the greatest risk I ever
took I didn't have you know I had less
than a thousand dollars to my name you
know and within 12 months of that move I
think I was now in the commercial world
I had a commercial music job and then
I'm spelling on TV you know and I have
to deal with that every day
and I'm so happy to be able to have this
balance but I have to you have to figure
out a way that you can just get the
balance just get the balance because
it's a constant back and forth you look
for those voices who can support you
don't feel ever feel isolated that
you're that you're alone because there's
other people who aren't going through
the same struggle that's that's my
institution that comfort commercial
world to just be the world that's mine
don't give up on your dream that's the
one thing that went in moving you give
up on your dream your time in your last
so go through the process we've all gone
through a process and figuring out how
we get to go to get to I read books I
would a journal I would set the passion
the brothers traveled all those things I
did all that and they grow that you
don't get back to dance and choreography
and directing and producing it and it's
hard and it's a it's not a lot of money
and you have to figure out how to you
know effectively write grants and fight
during funders and it's like an uphill
battle a lot of stuff because there's a
lot of competition but the dream I don't
want to do anything else this is slam
it's my passion so please and they also
at a point to visit Cooper okay so speak
to you for the interest of time I'm
gonna make sure that all of the contact
information for these amazing people are
somehow connected with the b-boying cast
website so that we can be
contact and have these conversations
please go ahead good evening my name is
Gretel scribbs
and I'm a lobbyist here in Boston and
Raskin Partners downtown Boston what
people always ask when I said that you
know what does something obvious do what
is the hell of that so we essentially
worked with policy stakeholders and
elected officials to influence their
decisions one way or another your
opposition heard or opponents part of
that is also Business Development and
one of my favorite of my 15 clients that
I have in my rolodex is axon enterprises
which is a tech company headquartered in
Scottsdale Arizona and they manufacture
two things one is a non-lethal weapon
also known as a Taser just carry about
police officers and the other is a
different variations of a body worn
camera for police so on the data
question and as I'm sure many of you
know the city of Boston is currently
going through a Boston body cam pilot
it's been one of the craziest political
houses I've seen in my life it's worse
than health care obviously but it is
it's been extended to being deliberated
northeast was doing a study of the data
of the cameras meanwhile the company
that we work with axon is pretty much a
leader there in 42 cities across the
United States and internationally it's
compared to the competitors like Apple
versus Android stars quality goes it's
all within a cloud you can redact the
video all the stuff it's pretty high
tech stuff Methuen Massachusetts the
only city investors actually has body
cameras on full deployment that's always
50 sworn officers so I guess my question
is part of a part of what we're doing
with this pilot Network and the Boston
Police is constantly meeting the City
Council was constantly with the police
commissioner that way too many copies of
that guy and and a lot of it is were us
strategizing
we moved and you know how do we get them
closer to full deployment of these body
cameras before and instead it happens
and not as a pre active thing and a lot
of it is I'm the only black dude at my
firm so I'm sitting there saying you
know we should probably apply some
pressure with some community groups so
some of you on call they don't yeah
called your phone and bugged you then
the way CP but but part of you know part
of part of what we're trying to do is is
mobilize community groups to say hey you
know Boston BPD you should put these
cameras on officers yesterday and so I
guess my my question well I would just
want to kind of stress to answer your
question the data that should be
covering is video that I think it is
data that is worn on officers that is
either on their chest or on the shoulder
on their glasses or data that is
recorded and sent directly to the DA's
office for for trying to recruit oh
instead of having to actually have two
squad car officers to carry over a CT
wrong if anybody knows what was our
anymore which wasted time and money but
then my question to you all who are who
work in social justice they work on
satisfiers
you know what are your thoughts on on
body cameras I know that that can't
necessarily solve the problem police
brutality or what have you but it
certainly in my opinion as I've been
advocating for the best 18 months or so
can stop them from quite frankly killing
us and I know that's just you know it's
the black community and the social
justice are almost not monolithic so
there's a whole bunch of different
dealers out there so I was just kind of
curious about that I just wanted to make
one comment to that
thinking about my own family in uncles
and brothers of the fifties who sent
those police officers and given that
issue this wonderful city that we live
in
I'm all for video data collection the
concern I have is is the city ready for
the secrets they're gonna be unveiled
because people know positions that have
been hiding and sneaking things off to
the side and then hang people whatever
if the truth was truly unveiled that
revealed all the shady [ __ ] that's been
happening for decades news in the city
ready to deal with those secrets we came
and apologized for sleeve they let them
know let's talk about black on black
crime and black men being lynched or
whatever the case is
what would the city look like if cops
were put in jail for the wrong would
this city be able to deal with that or
we go in that to very difficult times
that we try to get over so I'm offer
that but as the Commissioner Reagan is
BPD ready and with example is that set
for the rest of the state
if only my Siouxland is only doing it
because Boston right now is the
epicenter of being the first for
everything we do want to be the first
would be to see for our shape I don't
know I have no idea but that's my
comment so I think it's absolutely worth
it I just don't know if we're ready for
the secrecy to be unveiled right now I
think it's totally worth they also buy
my baby
what at guilty murder I think they show
I've seen the videos of a shot I've seen
you're not enemies we've recorded it
even from the outside I think that we
have to push policy that actually gets
them a guilty verdict I mean even thing
about today but I forgot I can't breathe
you think about that and those cops to
get off as much as all of us March to be
hashtag we've done our part but if we're
not changing the actual legal system you
know we're police in the police that's
likely they already notice still we've
already seen it we've seen shirring
today we've lived it some of us you know
what I mean and I'm also thinking about
what the body cameras when I was
watching a news room they're talking
about like surveillance of mass act what
are the parameters for that how far does
this surveillance really go because I
guess if I'm just walking my dog down to
Charles I don't need you guys staring at
me in my head so I'm thinking about we
have to kind of get beyond policing can
actually start being preventive and
protecting each other body cameras I
think the thing I'm thinking a little
more about some of the philosophical
issues and just thinking about the rest
of the conversation tonight and so
anyway search question so one of the
things with body cameras and the reason
it never Lisa who's at support of it
even even understanding that it was not
a permanent fixture or hardly cognitive
is the idea that people change new
behavior
watch so the hoff are in fact and then
it makes me think of the researcher that
data question and I'm also thinking
about Kenneth Kenneth Kenneth question
nothing like I've had all this since
childhood and sometimes it comes a
totally safe to its name for some reason
something about Ken so thinking that how
can i talked about how black people
exist currently in any United States and
how well regarded and so it's
interesting to me is to think about
ourselves usually as a subject of
research usually by bank researchers who
were not so usually under study usually
a spectacle usually under a microscope
and then with what's been interesting
about movements occurring today in black
labs medicine has been at the fore that
an engagement attempted to the to the
larger conversation anticipating the
examination of how exist so that that
questioning and rethinking who should be
studied so I'm thinking
as a Claudia retain something about
Claudia Rankine you know there was a
there's an article I think that came out
a couple of years ago the Washington
Post's that would ye absolutely
segregated neighborhoods and said what's
wrong with those neighborhoods because
we're he's just reduced to having
conversations and you talked about this
about what's wrong with us and what's
wrong with our communities or what's
what's going with with our neighborhoods
so that so what I think about the
research question and the data my assume
that they also then makes me think of
you know how we regard ourselves as as
subjects how we regard ourselves in
relation to in relation to everyone else
how we hold ourselves accountable how
there's a hyper criticality I think you
talked about that and and how we could
we could probably do it to make some
reexamination some questioning of
shifting the land
and start asking some different
questions and with the police they
whatever they think about me now as I
think about how every single time so I
personally am NOT a person who thinks
you know Jail turn away building product
is ultimate justice but what I do think
about if we're just thinking about
humanity we are telling people other
people I'm thinking about you talking
earlier just about the sanctity of human
life right now we are steadily telling
people who've killed other people that's
okay
and we're now we're steadily tallying
killers and murderers you're okay and
they're not yes you have a lot of people
you're fine you're healthy you gonna
take one good laughs thank you
we're gonna take one last comment or
question and then way better oh okay
one and one sorry we gotta go
my name is jonathan badly I'm gonna
commonest I'm not affiliated with any
actually but I did just want to kind of
boost art again I recognize that I'm a
white person in a black space and I like
walked up to the mic and I'm speaking
yeah and that that kind of intrusion is
sometimes we actually you talked about
it earlier so I wanted to kind of draw
up one of the things that you brought up
that that was most striking was that
when there's when there's an intrusion
into the Beehive all the bees have the
same they start going in the same
frequency so then I was thinking about
okay well
all right this is this huge component of
this work is that it's musical and I was
thinking about my experience with black
music especially jazz hip-hop and the
way that interacting with those those
art forms helps me understand and
reflect I think about the views that I
had so it's good I just wanted to kind
of respond to the question about how do
we change and I think black art is a way
that you can actually affect not just
the black community you can also affect
what community and there was also this
element where there's this wow you were
kind of worried about transforming from
b-boy yourself into a big girl and I was
thinking all right as an intruder like
I'm definitely not going to be come up
to you but I'm gonna I can like start to
understand that appreciate it so I just
wanted to say another positive thing
about like hard that black art actually
changes things that actually like
affects people so I was once a graduate
student here at MIT
culture and technology in the school of
architecture and we only publicly funded
our design college of the country and I
would say thank you
Wow nothing like this was happening when
I was a student here let me tell you
nothing like this exactly what I was
doing this is really amazing and I
appreciate the data question I
appreciate so much that's been talked
about so far and what's on my mind is
that you know the source of aggression
sources of aggression the problem is not
abstract so we're talking about
Charlotte asked like what what do we
need to come out of the sunken place and
I feel like saying things plain thinking
they can critically say things playing
and resisting the compulsion for denial
is something that I'm really working on
with my students and my relationships
with people of color and people and
white people also just to be very clear
and to be honest and to subscribe
I'm trying to watch myself for like
accepting denial as an acceptable
strategy you know I'm like so when so
like this stuff just happened at Fenway
Park right
nice racism definitely Park and I and I
was about six book and watching this for
a couple of my friends middle-aged white
men showed up on their on their walls
dismissing we invent as
that's a significant like oh well you
haven't been to enough parks have you
been to other games or you know before
years ago what kids were busted to black
neighborhoods that one night so you know
like just weird
the way again we'll talked about what
happens in time with these you know
toxic stress is produced inside of us
when we have to deal and you have let me
move around the stuff you know when
we're around truth so one of the really
often things that I've learned about
data from my best friend Nia and why she
rose three of my heroes
I've learned later in life were all
focused on education as a as a tool as a
shield and sward Thurgood Marshall and I
take the butler and it always comes back
to education think about this if you
think about this time in particular it's
such such it's so historically known for
being so flustered with the fact that
education and educational equity is the
battleground
that's where everything changes where
these people lost their office creating
and stuff it means like in 1853 you know
I mean like so I feel like as far as
like data goes beside the fact that we
need to be understanding like how how to
produce food again those muscles
forgotten if like been removed from
those roots
I feel like understanding understanding
what's being taken a lot of us know a
lot of us have no idea how significant
Brown versus Board of Education was to
all public space all public space was
transformed by that case it was the
Trojan horse they gave us the small
and PBS and everything else magnet
schools and incidents such as for
infrared studies and arts was the crux
of that transformational strategy art
and integration so that we can learn to
love each other and humanize each other
and see each other as full human beings
from an early age and look at what these
people are hot to to look at what people
have been hot to burn up ever since is
access to education look at just this
town 20 years to abide by that unanimous
Supreme Court decision that Supreme
Court decision that would never happen
today that would never happen today so I
feel like um I get so much I just so
much that I don't know and I feel like I
get so much from from from learning
about these court cases because this is
where the this is where the battle is so
in the court cases oversee housing
justice and injustice medical mental you
know medical experimentation and it's
not abstract and the source of the
source of these aggression the the way
that we are dying as people not have
bodies but as human beings it's not
abstract at all but the beautiful thing
about art and its art if this continues
to be this this miraculous Trojan horse
that allows us to learn experientially
after the makers and that's the
consumers and so it's always it's always
with richer with possibility to bring us
together and wiser people than any of us
have known that for a long time I think
[Applause]
okay we got her back this up but I just
I thought I would just end with a quote
from James Baldwin DVD James Baldwin
love does not begin and end the way we
seem to think it does love was a battle
love is a war love is a growing up thank
you all so much for being here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]